i'm amazed by people's abilities
to build companies or
incredible art but for me to admire
someone
that means they've done something that
really touched my soul
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
gary vaynerchuk hey how's it going it's
going well how are you
i'm doing good gary good so um
so gary this is uh this is a podcast
recording for the mindvalley podcast but
one of the things that we do a little
bit differently is that we have a live
audience watching us so we have about
uh 170 people right now it'll probably
go up to about 300 people
and the audience these are mindvalley's
biggest fans have been helping me come
up with questions for you
first how are you going how are you
doing i know the world is
being so different lately i'd lean into
gratitude and perspective
and accountability during these times
and
um that's it that's all i can do
well one thing i got to say about you
gary is that i i love
the positivity that you bring on stage
um
so just a little backstory but i
remember about a year ago we were
speaking on stage together
in in sharjah near dubai
right um you opened the conference i
closed the conference but what really
touched me
is how when you got on stage at that
audience in in sharjah
you were able to adapt your message
adapt your style
to an arab audience so effortlessly
thank you for saying that
and at the same time i've seen you speak
in vegas and it's a completely different
garyvee
um this was at tony robbins business
freedom mastery summit way
way back um we've shut the stage several
times but we
we've only met once at a pizza joint in
summit series
many years ago aboard a ship but uh just
want to express my gratitude for having
a guest here thank you for having me
i've been watching you for 10 years and
amazed at how you've grown
now because of how in
in like when you speak gary you just go
on a roll so i do not want to interrupt
you and unnecessary questions
i want to give you a space to share your
message to our audience today the people
who are watching
are mostly 60 leaders managers
entrepreneurs
and they are all here as part of the
mindvalley community because they love
personal growth and these 300 people
showed up live
because they love you
it's very sweet i'm so excited to be
here let's rock and roll
so with everything happening in the
world right now what would be your
advice to entrepreneurs
you know you know i think it is going
into you know it was funny when i just
answered your question
i realized if i organized this is
literally how i create content
this crew will probably see a video
tonight at 7 30 p.m
eastern american time where
the title at the top is going to say go
into your gap
during times like this because
serendipitously i decided to answer
you with you know with gratitude
accountability and perspective i ordered
it differently but as you and i were
talking i reordered it into spelling the
word gap
and so i'm actually gonna make that
piece of content like i literally have
just decided right here serendipitous
never put those words together
so that's fun and it's an insight to how
i think which is like
creativity information being skilled at
something it requires omni presence it's
not you know you know
you can go train like i can go train to
be a skier but i'm not going to be a
world world-class skier
for me entrepreneurship and really
wisdom and perspective
came natural to me it's my natural state
so you know what do i tell entrepreneurs
i tell them
this is what you signed up for like to
really go
there what i tell fellow entrepreneurs
is like this is our time
like when things are challenging when
they're difficult
when they're not stable is exactly when
entrepreneurs do well
a pure a real entrepreneur i don't like
using the word real but like
an entrepreneur not someone over the
last decade when i got cooler
decided they wanted to be one but an
entrepreneur
uh it's like being a fish and now here's
the water
like to me this is our time this is when
you have to
navigate um this is all we know
like you've signed up for
a world where you have to react to
realities on a daily basis and it's all
on your
accountable shoulders and then when
they're
um incapable of going there i
deployed perspective and gratitude i
remind my friends some who've been
struggling
that if covet started six weeks earlier
kobe bryant would be alive
you know you could you can decide to
look at all the bad
you know go look at the traffic deaths
data
around the world you know you start
getting into scary debates of
where more people's lives saved during
this time than lost
it's half glass full half glass empty
you know you start getting into really
interesting thoughtful places and so for
me
it's perspective you know i think about
world war
ii i think about the black plague i
think about
so many genocides i think about the
people and
the millions of people around the world
that don't have clean water
every day not when there's not covet i'm
not capable of dwelling
because of gap you know gratitude
accountability you know like what am i
gonna do about it
and perspective and so i'm what do i say
i say we should be thankful that we can
even have this conversation
health over everything and uh
and let's um you know let's let's move
forward
i love that gap concept so gratitude we
get gratitude
tell us about accountability
accountability is tricky
because people confuse accountability
with lack of compassion
and i don't see it that way you know i
view accountability as
what can i control and so you know when
when things like this happen people
blame you know people want to blame
china people want to blame their own
government people want to blame their
boss
their spouse the system and
oftentimes there's validity in those
things the question becomes what are you
going to do about it
you know you can go political and talk
about voting you can talk about people
that are really suppressed places about
leaving if they can you know some places
you can't even leave but leaving if you
can
you know for me it's accountability what
can i do you know
when a lot of our in a very small not as
heady
conversation when my company is in
trouble
when covet hits because clients are
telling us they're not going to pay they
have to reduce scopes
you know first i stop paying myself then
i stop
wasting money on dumb stuff so i look at
all our expenses
then unfortunately the worst of the
bunch i have to let some people go
so the whole company can pay its bills
you know life and so i like
accountability
like i like you know what am i gonna do
about it and i don't think it's fun
or healthy to feel helpless and i think
it leads to a lot of
bad things that doesn't mean that i
don't have compassion for people that
are in precurious positions
it's just that i think it's very
empowering
for people to try to hack to think
what are they going to do
now the final one was perspective the p
we've already touched on that which is i
use perspective and gratitude a lot
my perspective leads to gratitude you
know
it could be worse right my perspective
is it could be worse
so as you went through this disruptive
period like what were some of the
the life lessons the uh the big insights
that you gained
i got affirmation from who i think i am
you know
during ironically oh my god today is 9
11. so
9 11 was the first major event i had to
navigate through as a leader
i was a very young kid in a family
business then there was the great
recession in 2008
as these are macro things as an
entrepreneur and operator every day
you're dealing with micro things
lawsuits somebody's family's issues
clients employees but macro 911
great recession but i always in the back
of my mind my friend
knew one thing 9 11 i was a kid i had
you know i had no expenses the great
recession
you know the reality was i built the
business for my dad
not for myself the first time so even in
2008 i really didn't have a lot
you know at an apartment but not a whole
lot you know
i didn't have kids yet so i always knew
in the back of my mind that i got
i was a great entrepreneur and i was
fearless and i put the
everything on my back but i really
didn't have a lot to lose
so i always wondered what would happen
not what would when the next big thing
happened this is me
five years ago four years ago three
years ago when that happens
am i gonna be as good navigating when
i'm clearly losing things
money leisure you know who knows what
status whatever it may be fun and uh
the biggest thing i learned is i'm built
for this [ __ ]
i'm born for this you know like i went
right into the place where i needed to
be
i knew what my requirement was as a
leader so i got affirmation of my
intuition of who i am
and i think i'm a wartime general i
think i'm at my best
when it's most adverse and i think
that's because i grew up in adverse
situations so it was
that was nice so that was something i've
learned i've learned
that um people are
i i i was affirmed my
my suspicion that people were soft and
entitled
you know this is where i keep going back
to back gap
you know like i you know people
like we're not entitled to have
everything come easy i don't know why
people think we are
it's not part of the life you know
journey like look at history you know
like
bad things happen and like really really
bad things happen
and i think people have become too
materialistic
and and have gotten complicated in their
need for acknowledgement from outside
forces
based on commercial successes
or what car they drive status it's a
we're
very deeply globally globally a very
deeply
um insecure
animal and we need other people's
opinions for validation
and i wish people could get validation
from their process
not from the things that their process
allows them to buy
to make them look good to others so
you know i've learned some human truths
that were suspicions
um and uh and i also
learned that every situation is
different i'm speaking in generalities
right now
there's seven billion people plenty of
people have excelled plenty of people
don't need a bmw to look cool they just
like how it drives
you know you know more affirmation
around me knowing that there are
thematics i'm passionate about and i'm
sharing them now
but every individual is different going
through their own cycle and i have a lot
of
um compassion and empathy for that
that's amazing that's beautiful so the
audience uh we now have 500 people live
the audience has a series of questions
for you
can we take some questions from the
audience gary of course of course so the
first question
is from jason halser do you still
believe in the hustle
absolutely now i think the word
when i used it in 2009 a lot meant hard
work
i think the word has been manipulated in
society in the last
you know half decade to mean burn out
you know and and so i've i've switched
using it more in a
world of like you know people you know
when a word changes its meaning to a
large group of people you have to
acknowledge that so
i use the word work ethic a lot more i
will forever believe in work ethic
there's nothing accomplished without the
execution and i believe in work ethic
and i'm uh
not to the expense of someone's health
or mental status
but i'm a very very big advocate i would
argue that i believe in work ethic more
today
than i did a decade ago so if you have
to
break it down right when you say work
epic what does that
look like for you like you know how you
came up with that acronym gap
is work ethic for you uh it's like
there's
we can all agree that there's a certain
amount of liquid in this bucket right
to me that's work ethic like there is
like everyone
in here and you know reading these
incredible comments observations
questions
everybody in here is got different skill
sets
in different things so if i put in seven
hours a day into learning how to cook
over time i could be a much much better
cook but i may not be as great
as jason halser or jan mckinney or anna
because they just actually had talent
along with their work ethic so there is
a talent work ethic thing
but it takes an enormous amount of work
to be beyonce or lebron
and or probably every single person
um you know here right every one of us
are gonna really struggle to not
recognize that the hours put into our
craft
our execution the time you put into your
children your employees
uh making this trying to figure out the
formula for this
like you know for me it's listening i
spend so much time listening you know
everybody sees me talking all the time
but i spend 90
of my time listening it's why i have
early observations on things
you know and so i work at that that's me
putting in four hours last night
reading twitter instagram forums reddit
you know like i read people's comments
like i that's why i have a poll so i'm
an anthropologist i'm a strategist that
way
so you know i believe in it i believe
it's putting in the work
it's like push-ups i think everyone here
working on their craft and things of
that nature
you know doing push-ups if you do eight
of them certain things happen if you do
80 of them a day
a different thing happens now we all
have different muscle composition
so some of us may show more but the work
is the work is the work it does matter
oh my god that that is so interesting
because 10 years ago
10 years ago you told me that you
literally
respond to every customer email like
back then it was email right this was
like
10 years ago when you were running wine
library team and by the way my friend
the reason the garyvee thing happened
was the four years on twitter where i
replied to everybody who tweeted me
and reached out to people talking about
wine and then social media
like there is no people know who i am
without the work i put in to establish
context and then
and then my upside was predicated on how
much value i was providing
i put in the work but if all the things
i've been saying through the years was
to get people to
come into my funnel and sign up for my
course and or like if i wasn't doing the
right thing by people
or or or you know i have the receipts
they're all on the internet
you go look back at my stuff that i
talked about in 9 10 11
12 13 a remarkable percentage
became true that's going to give me
affirmation
of a reputation you know people talk
about personal brand and then
people like i hate that term i'm like
call it what you want it's called your
reputation
you know me being right about a lot of
things was better for me than me being
wrong about those things
okay so this is insane because when you
told me about how you respond to every
single email i was like
i was incredulous i was like yeah right
now but
that's not going to sustain itself 10
years from now and here we are 10 years
later
and you just told me you spent four
hours replying no
oh last night correct now now that was a
little different
similar but different last night i was
reading comments about
subject matters i did reply to some of
my stuff
to your point it was not just you know i
remember when i was doing it everyone's
like it's not sustainable i'm like
and then it won't be right i didn't i
didn't have
my pride in it i knew that it was a nice
thing to do
i was learning i was making connections
i always to this day i think this way
this is why
hopefully if some of you've met me
you've got a sense of me
i will never big time anybody i came
from the dirt
yeah dirt i don't have it in me to big
time somebody
i'm when i i promise you every time
somebody says garyvee
i'm so grateful i'm so flattered
you know and so i will never take that
for granted that somebody appreciates
my work i i will never i will go to the
grave and i by the way
on the record i don't even think i've
started yet
i left that statement i really am
telling you the truth like
you know as you know 10 years ago i
started making some juice i'd already
built a big business for my dad so i had
some credibility
and i mean i'm in a totally different
stratosphere than i was back then
and that's exactly how i feel right now
of who i'm going to be at 54 because i
think
i have good intent i believe in what i'm
doing i'm working
hard i'm working fair and i'm doing the
things that
you know lead to good things gary what
is it that really matters to you
like what is it that you wake up every
day excited to do and to give to the
world
i have this weird blend of guilt and
gratitude
that i was gifted circumstances
and an ability to communicate and i want
to leave that
i want to leave that i i i want that
legacy selfishly
and i want my i'm addicted to admiration
right and i think that admiration is
only earned you don't
you know admiration doesn't come that
they're like let me rephrase
my definition of admiration is you don't
get admiration
unless you really do something really
meaningful deep like
like i'm i'm amazed by
athletes i'm amazed by certain people's
general beauty i'm amazed by
people's abilities to build companies or
incredible art
but for me to admire someone that means
they've done
something that really touched my soul
like
left like they're incredibly um
just kind and generous and
and just they are their humanity is on a
scale
above the rest and i'm very focused on
trying to create that now that comes at
the contrast of being a businessman
that's not where the world is looking at
businesses but
but it is my truth i i love doing
business
and i love nice i'm addicted to nice so
i want to leave
a legacy where people feel compelled
to come to my funeral one day or or tell
their
daughter a story or whatever the social
network of the day is or however we
communicate
um you know to to say something nice
i want to do that i want to live that
life that is super interesting to me
that's beautiful beautiful i love that
and you definitely
resonate kindness i've noticed that
about you a number of times
so here's a question from adam is asking
i've been following you for two years
now wonderful to hear you
see to see you here on mindvalley what
advice do you have for people
starting a new career mid-life
contextualize that you're early i think
a lot of people when they think
midlife don't realize how early that is
and they feel this
pressure that they need this to work
once you take the pressure out that you
might make this switch
and it might not work which you can then
go back to the old thing or try a third
thing
if you could eliminate that pressure
because it's about calibrating time if
you have a good relationship with time
and realize
how old is he if you could if you can
just was it adam i'm sorry
i didn't adam how old are you post it in
the comments you know i want to see it
for context
and maybe it's not even for him maybe
adam if it's not for you if it's for
your mom or dad or somebody else put the
number of that age
41. yeah and adam is it for you you can
just say yes or what have you
you know like you know to me
if if it's for adam let's say at 41
years old he's
uncomfortably young
like there's a really good chance on a
conservative day he's got 25 years of
profession in front of him
which is more time than he's already put
in
since he was 18 to 22. think about that
but that's not what we do my friend we
don't do that we do not do a good job
in having a relationship with time we
think at 41 we're old because society
has done a very bad job
of creating time because we're going off
to we're going off of old
norms where people did live to 50 or 60
but we're living to 80 90 and 100
and because of our health and wellness
initiatives as a global society
we at 41 and mentally the youthification
of our society all of a sudden 41 is
really 25
but nobody feels that and so
you know that's my biggest advice which
is take the pressure out you know when i
see amber at 34 in here
like [ __ ] man i look at 34 and i'm like
ugh by the way i restarted my life at 34
at 34.
i had spent my entire life 12 years
building a business for my dad
in a family business i didn't get paid
what i was worth i built a business from
3 to 65 million
i was never making any real money at all
because it was a family business you
know you inherit it when your dad dies
i leave at 34 i owe nothing i don't own
the wine library
i have no money on paper to get to
borrow it even
but i [ __ ] built it so i've had this
huge 12-year accomplishment
and what i get for it is to start over
with zero
and i'm thrilled because i accomplished
what i wanted which is i wanted to do
something great for my parents
that took humility and patience i'm at
34. i start vaynermedia
in the conference room of buddy media
because i don't have any money for us to
pay rent
i did not know that so i'm i started
over at 34.
wow and being a media what year was that
that must have been 2009 2010 right i
was born in 75.
wow wow you're about a year older than
me
you know and so you know this goes back
to excuses and countability sometimes i
mean people are like yeah but your dad
handed you something i'm like that's
what you've manipulated my story into
let me tell you the truth interesting
that firstly so much respect for you i
did not know that part of your story
well i'll tell you why you don't know it
i'll let me tell you why um let me take
it even further yeah you know why you
don't know it
because i didn't want to make i thought
when i started getting notoriety that i
didn't want to tell that story
because i thought that it didn't shed
good light on my dad
uh-huh right i thought that some people
would take it as like my dad [ __ ] me
because i'm an immigrant and i know that
our framework is different than the
masses
yeah you were born in belarus that's
right so i
you know i didn't want to you know i
love
my parents right i just and and then it
became a detriment
because you can imagine after you do
that to live a life where people
try to throw an excuse at you that the
reason you were successful
is you were given something when i was
part of the very small
0.001 percent that gave to my parents
[ __ ] you right oh my god that that's
that's a beautiful aspect of your story
yeah a lot of people don't know you were
born in belarus um if you google gary
you'll see american bella russian
entrepreneur my ex-wife was from belarus
so um um i know the culture belarus
by the way with with everything
happening in belarus are you
do you feel a connection to that do you
but my parents fear me being too loud
about it because
you know what dictate you know the
soviet union scared
families scared people yeah yeah
yeah i know what that's like gary the
next thing i want to ask you is as you
spoke about
age and our perspective of age one of
the things i realized that i'm biased
about is tick tock you just
you've been raving about tick tock my
six-year-old daughter came up to me
a week ago and she said daddy you need
to be on tick-tock
and i have an 11-year-old friend who can
teach you and
so in my mind tick tock is like for kids
you are
45 and you are crushing it on tick tock
tell us about that why is tick tock
relevant it's relevant because
a every platform that ever becomes
a big platform often starts young
and then ages up you know don't forget
everybody
there's not a 17 year old on earth a 20
year old on earth that wants a facebook
account
and it used to be the most important
place 10 years ago
right so for me when something emerges
and has that scale of attention i'm
always going to go look at it because
i'm a strategist for not only myself but
for everything i do in business
i might start a candy company or a
sneaker company so i need to know what's
going on tick tock
two i need to know how to use it so i
always put myself
you know in that environment three
what's happened on tick tock
is what's going on on tik tok which is
it is now dominant for
20 30 and 40 year olds at scale across
the globe
so and that is with enormous amounts of
effort
from different governments to try to
paint it as an extremely dangerous app
doing things that you don't understand
there's been an incredible
amount of media and government
efforts india american other superpowers
against it and
still the consumer continues to speak
with its behavior
you can imagine how much it's resonating
with the compute consumer i don't
i don't have emotion i don't have any
opinion i don't feel like my opinions on
social networks
should be other people's opinions and i
respect people's opinions
i also ask them to explain you know i've
had tons of conversations like tell me
how tick-tock's dangerous well
it's china and they know not they know
what they know what you know there's not
spyware going into your phone
we can prove that you can look you know
like so it's those kind of questions
i see i see so in terms of
entrepreneurship today what would be
your advice to entrepreneurship
in terms of building their personal
brand getting their message out if
they just don't feel comfortable getting
in front of a camera or sharing their
voice
find out if you're comfortable in a
medium that does work for you because a
lot of people don't
feel comfortable in front of a camera
and i understand that insecurity about
one
the way one looks is a huge thing for
the world
uh um genuinely enjoying privacy and not
wanting to be known out there like
there's a million reasons why and that's
amazing
maybe you should write you know writing
is an incredible way writing blog posts
writing copy maybe you're a photographer
and you can write a couple sentences so
all of a sudden instagram works
maybe you don't like to talk in camera
but you love to talk and you can record
it and you can build a huge
you know podcast find a medium that does
work for you and oh by the way
if nothing can be found then that's okay
too you're just leaving a lot of
opportunity on the table and that's okay
too
okay right yeah yeah the important point
and
you know this is what's fun about
maturing
you know i find myself articulating
things
out loud now that i used to think people
understood and were assumed when i
talked
so i look back at old content like i was
more definitive
like it was these absolute hard
statements and i thought
that and wrongfully that it was
contextualized through the breadth of
everything i was saying
now i think i'm more thoughtful of
delivering what i just said which was
he find a medium oh by the way if you
can't that's okay
and you know but but recognize much like
work ethic you're going to leave some
opportunity on a table and guess what
if you want to build a great business
plenty of people build it without
building a personal brand now
if you build it it will lead to things
not to mention the thing that i'm doing
it for my great great great great
grandkids are going to really really
know me
no i mean this i mean this like yes i
like the fact that garyvee brings
business for vaynermedia and other
things that's good
but that's tiny what i really like is my
when i'm 87
and i give some advice to my
granddaughter she's gonna be able to go
back
and look at something i said in 2015
that was consistent to something i'm
telling her
in 2064 and i think it's gonna land
better because she's not gonna think old
granddad is just trying to [ __ ] tell
her that
she's gonna be like [ __ ] this guy really
believes that
i love that i love that but gary don't
you think it's getting
way too competitive media you have
people like
shetty of course mass turned it into a
source
of course that's good it should be
merit-based
but doesn't that set the boss so high
for the rest of us
no no it just means that what you're
gonna get is what you're gonna get
that would have happened if those people
are alive or not
nobody the world is abundant let there
be no confusion
the world is abundant me and anybody
else
we are not taking eyeballs away from you
there are plenty of eyeballs
that's just the truth it's just true you
know it's just
true the question you just asked is the
same question i was asked two years ago
four years ago six years ago eight years
ago and there's
many more people on now and i'll be
asked again in 20 years and it's still
going to be the same answer the world is
abundant
you are going to get what you're going
to get nobody's you know i've met a lot
of people like oh that influencer's
taking my audience
i'm like first of all it's not your
audience the audience is
the audience nobody owns anything number
two there are 7.7 billion people on
earth
there's plenty of audience for you and
if you're bringing value and somebody
else is bringing value in a similar
genre because no two people are the same
they're going to consume both actually
good job
sarma like they're gonna they're gonna
consume both
that's great okay so kimberly asked and
gary i don't know how much time you have
i have my i have my internal team on a
zoom here now so i want to sneak one
quick one in right now
last one i apologize so the the final
question here is
on kindness kimberly says she's so
appreciative that you preached the
the mantra of kindness but andrew casey
asks
how do you deal with people who try to
take advantage of your kindness
nobody can take advantage of kindness
people take advantage of people that
allow them to take advantage
and let me explain that because it's
very subtle i hear this a lot it's a
great question thank you for it
you're not being taken advantage of
because you're kind
you're being taken advantage of you're
you're being taken advantage because of
two things
one and this one really hurts people
when i pick at them
especially usually one-on-one with a
friend is because you're letting them
take advantage of you
because you're expecting something on
the back end and that was your way to
get them
in and when they don't deliver on it
because you aren't candorous
you blame them not yourself
or you are wildly insecure
and need affirmation and so you're just
letting someone take advantage of you
to feel a quick adrenaline rush or a
door
a hit of appreciation because you
yourself are hurting
those are the only two things you're
either trying to manipulate somebody
subconsciously
or maybe consciously or two you yourself
are not in a strong
place and you need a quick feeling of
appreciation even though you know
deep down it's not true and then it
hurts in the end those are the only
times you get taken advantage of
not because you're kind i'm the kindest
oh man i'm real kind out here
and i'm not getting taken advantage ever
amazing gary gary thank you so much we
know you gotta run
making this appearance on mindvalley uh
really by the way
kudos to you on this format the app the
pushback the curiosities the doubling
down the affirmation
of the attendees during this brought an
incredible dynamic
similar to why i really enjoy public
speaking
and i i can't thank you enough for
innovating i think it's a great format
and kudos to you
and for all of you that were commenting
here real real love please feel free to
say hello any platform i know you can
find me
bye everyone thanks thank you gary hey
everybody on youtube first of all thank
you so much so humbled for your time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out